Christian Bale is Anakin Skywalker
Nicholas Cage is Aragorn it may be hard
to imagine but some of your favorite
movies almost featured someone else
entirely in leading roles in 1977 Star
Wars wasn't yet the massive cultural
Juggernaut it is now but there was still
a lot of Buzz around its production this
was mainly due to the fact that young
George Lucas the writer director of Star
Wars was just coming off the success of
his 1975 period teen dromedy American
Graffiti although Star Wars was seen by
the studio execs at the time as a bomb
in the making due to the dubious
failures of many recent Sci-Fi films
Lucas's early auteur status still got
actors interested in working with them
one of the roles that got the most
attention was the smug Devil May care
space mugler Han Solo the actors who
showed up to audition were the who's who
of the era including Christopher Walken
Al Pacino and probably most famously
Kurt Russell
while many of these actors could have
pulled off a good hunt we're lucky that
Harrison Ford who had also worked on
George Lucas's American Graffiti got the
gig in the end who knows if Star Wars
would have worked as well without his
patented salty but still soft at heart
charm the 1997 epic romance Drama
Titanic directed by action Maestro James
Cameron turned out to be one of the most
successful films of all time and one of
the only non-franchise films in the top
10 highest grossing movies of all time
even before Titanic earned historic box
office rankings James Cameron was
standing on top of the world due to his
back to back to back Blockbuster
successes the alien sequel aliens and
the first two Terminator films despite
skepticism about the director working
outside of his comfort zone with the
period romance Cameron was able to earn
back his inflated budget at the box
office as well as push CGI technology to
its limit for the time still none of
that would matter without a good human
connection at the center of the
spectacle without characters to care
about it would end up just being empty
eye candy because of that James Cameron
took a long time to find the perfect
couple to help anchor the lumbering epic
this meant unlinked the audition phase
including offers the then Heavy Hitters
like Claire Danes and Gwyneth pal outro
after seeing a lot of other prospective
actors Kate Winslet got the part with
her Talent paying off
I don't like sand
it's coarse
rough and irritating
when it gets everywhere from Toys to
books to cartoons and even live action
TV series Star Wars is seemingly
omnipresent this was especially true in
the late 90s to mid-2000s when the
prequels reign supreme at the box office
Star Wars Episode 2 attack of the Clones
was extremely popular and profitable
apparently over 700 young hopeful actors
were lining up for a chance to play the
hunky breed Darth Vader Anakin Skywalker
according to an Insider Source at the
time lucasfilm wanted everyone to have a
chance at the roll the Anakin hopefuls
included Chris Klein Ryan Phillippe
Bridgeton Bale Keith Ledger and Leonardo
DiCaprio ultimately Hayden Christensen
best known at the time for his role in
the 2001 drama Life as a House
infamously nabbed the roll the casting
Choice was initially met with kosh's
optimism but the fans quickly soured on
his portrayal upon the film's release in
2002. luckily fans seem to have warmed
up on Christensen since since then
1995's Mortal Kombat was an early
outlier of video game movies with a good
box office showing and decent reviews
including a thumbs up from Gene Siskel
it had amazing fight scenes showing Hong
Kong wire food stunts years before the
Matrix it also got a fun script slick
direction from Paul W S Anderson and a
fun cast this includes the lead Liu Kang
played by a Hong Kong American actor
Robin Shu who was a great center of the
film bringing the role a sense of
strength integrity and true leadership
but it wasn't easy Chu recalled the
grueling audition experience to The
Hollywood Reporter it was the toughest
casting process I read seven times my
agent friend had never heard of anyone
who had to read seven times I had to
read for the producers the director the
casting director the line producer and
then my final reading was with new line
Shu even considered giving up luckily he
didn't because Mortal Kombat wouldn't be
the same without him in the lead role
the Mighty Morphin Power Rangers TV
series and its various sequels were
seriously popular in the 1990s debuting
in 1993 the original show was created by
Heim Saban who bought the rights to the
Japanese tokuzatsu show Super Sentai
which depicted a group of Heroes and
colorful helmets in spandex fighting off
evil Kaiju Monsters Saban's crew filmed
cheap English language interstitials
with young American actors between
fighting scenes creating a mess of style
and tones that somehow still worked the
show inspired two Power Rangers films in
the 90s each starring the TV cast the
first was released in 1995 with the
sequel turbo A Power Rangers Movie
released in 1997. then after over 20
Power Rangers spin-off shows Lionsgate
decided to produce a gritty reboot of
the initial Mighty Morphin Power Rangers
in 2017. an epic big budget feature film
starring an all-new cast of teens with
two despite the ultimate critical and
Commercial disappoint of the 2017 Power
Rangers reboot the hype for the film
before its release was palpable many
young actors who were in their teens or
early 20s gave it a shot including
up-and-comers such as KJ APA Austin
Butler Mitchell hope Stephanie Scott and
Ross Butler ultimately Ludy Lynn Naomi
Scott Baker Montgomery Becky G and RJ
Kyler were cast as the new Power Rangers
M Night shyamalan's critically acclaimed
breakthrough horror film The Sixth Sense
made Haley Joel Osmond a star and landed
him a best supporting actor Oscar
nomination at the ripe old age of 11.
Cole Seer the little boy who can
communicate with the dead was a plum
roll and lots of Hollywood's youngest
actors were eager to see dead people in
the 1999 flick Liam Aiken the star
stepmom and later A Series of
Unfortunate Events auditioned for
Shyamalan he wanted the role badly but
his mother declined due to his age in
the dark subject matter while he's
mostly now known as a comedic actor
Michael Sarah also auditioned to play
the sensitive troubled coal in an
interview with Esquire Sarah recalled
not knowing the character sees dead
people and instead playing a serious
emotional audition scene with a lot of
optimism origin stories are all the rage
these days so it's not surprising that
MGM Warner Brothers and GK Films decided
to reboot the Tomb Raider film franchise
nearly 15 years after Angelina Jolie
last on the popular video game heroines
Infamous hot pants when asked about the
film director Rohr utag told GQ this
movie will introduce Laura as a young
woman who hasn't yet found her way and
her place in the world not long after
the project was announced a host of
Hollywood's hottest young female Talent
lined up to try to snag the park
including Saoirse Ronan and Emilia
Clarke Star Wars heroine Daisy Ridley
was in serious talks with the casting
team at one point But ultimately The
Producers went with Oscar winner Alicia
vikander the quest to find the perfect
actor to play the future king of Gondor
was almost as long as Frodo and Sam's
journey to Mordor when Peter Jackson and
his team set out to adapt J.R.R
tolkien's fantasy epic the Lord of the
Rings for the Silver Screen they
launched an exhaustive worldwide casting
search that included quite a few of
Hollywood's heaviest hitters many of
whom were eyed for the role of Aragorn
Nicholas Cage turned it down telling
Newsweek there were different things
going on in my life at the time that
precluded me from being able to travel
and be away from home for three years
three-time Oscar winner Daniel Day-Lewis
also famously said no citing fear of
being bored Russell Crowe considered
joining the fellowship but budget
constraints caused him to pull out
Stuart Townsend age 27 was finally cast
and trained for over two months but was
replaced with Viggo Mortensen just
before filming began as Jackson felt
Townsend was too young for the role I
would have gone with you to the end
the very fires
Aragorn wasn't the only one sought far
and wide in Peter Jackson's Lord of the
Rings The Heart of the entire Trilogy
rests on the tiny shoulders and big
hairy feet of Frodo Baggins
unfortunately Jackson had trouble
finding the perfect photo a character
who had to embody so many different
attributes in one person most notably a
real sense of kindness and purity of Art
in an interview with Charlie Rose
Jackson said he'd seen over 200 would-be
photos at one point and almost none of
them seemed quite right for the role
this included star Jake Gyllenhaal who
after his historically disastrous
audition was coldly told by Jackson that
he was the worst actor he'd ever seen
fortunately former Child Star Elijah
Wood who was a fan of The Hobbit novel
and Peter Jackson's early horror work
jumped at the chance to audition he even
hired a dialect coach and videotaped
himself on VHS to ship to Jackson
himself that tape was apparently enough
to convince Jackson that wood was the
guy to take the more than three your
journey the film The Epic Trilogy it's
hard to imagine anyone but Ewan McGregor
and Nicole Kidman as the ill-fated
lovers in Boz lerman's hypnotic movie
musical Moulin Rouge but the Visionary
Aussie director saw tons of actors
during a lengthy audition process Lerman
was particularly impressed by Jake
Gyllenhaal telling MTV the actor has a
wonderful voice interestingly it was
during these auditions when Gyllenhaal
met his future Brokeback Mountain
co-star Heath Ledger who was also being
considered Ledger even went so far as to
read scenes with Nicole Kidman but
Lerman went with McGregor when they
changed Christian's age making Ledger
too young though Kidman wound up eseteen
whole front woman Courtney Love also
auditioned for the consumptive courtesan
Lerman found her intriguing and though
she wasn't cast love helped him attain
the rights to relate husband Kurt Cobain
song Smells Like Teen Spirit for the
film Superman is perhaps the most iconic
superhero in the history of the genre
while he wasn't the first superhero to
get his own film you was the first
superhero to get the big budget
treatment that's standard today in the
late 1970s producer Alexander salkind
got the rights to Superman and tapped
The Omen director Richard Donner to helm
the superhero epic sawkine was looking
to get an a-lister to wear the iconic
spandex tights and Cape among them were
Nick Nolte Clint Eastwood Robert Redford
Sylvester Stallone and Harrison Ford
Donner on the other hand advocated for
an unknown actor to play Superman so the
character could shine without being
bogged down by a star Persona The
Producers initially disagreed but cooler
heads ended up prevailing ultimately
they went with the relatively unknown 24
year old Juilliard trained actor
Christopher Reeve who turned into the
ideal Superman even to this day
[Applause]
don't flip
yeah despite being one of the most
recognizable comic book superheroes of
all time Spider-Man had a hard time
getting his Hollywood debut after
Scripps and projects bounced around for
many years the rights to Spider-Man
eventually reverted to Marvel who sold
them to Sony Pictures Entertainment in
1999. Sam raimi's iconic Spider-Man
trilogy later inspired the Marvel
Cinematic Universe after Spider-Man 3
there was uncertainty about if
Spider-Man would ever join the iconic
film franchise luckily Disney and Sony
reached an agreement with Spider-Man
making his first MCU appearance in
2016's Captain America Civil War almost
every major Young Star aged 15 to 25
came in to read for the MCU version of
Spider-Man including Timothy chalamet
Asa Butterfield and Miss Marvel co-star
Matt Lentz the casting web was spread so
wide that the actor who ended up
sticking was relatively unknown theater
star Tom Holland who at the time was
best known for the stage musical version
of Billy Elliot one of the most
disappointing Cinema Trends in recent
years is the dreaded Disney Live Action
remake this includes director guy
Ritchie's 2019 Aladdin live action
remake one of the bright spots of the
Aladdin film however is its casting
according to Julie Ann Gromit Disney's
vice president of Multicultural
engagement casting took half a year and
demanded travel to over a dozen
countries to find just the right actors
to authentically portray Aladdin and
Princess Jasmine luckily they landed on
the Egyptian Canadian actor Mina Masood
to play Aladdin and Naomi Scott as the
aforementioned Princess Jasmine they
were joined by Will Smith as the genie
previously voiced by late comedian Robin
Williams everyone was able to take their
animated counterparts and do them
Justice while also adding their own
Flair and personalities to them
[Music]